ايران اذا تصاعد قمع هذا ضد المتظاهرين
الذين يبدو انهم مصرون على المضيق قدما في
هذه الثوره وفقا وصف الرئيس الفرنسي الذي
اغضب ولا يزال نظاما طهران عقب لقائه
باربعه ناشطات يناضلنا من اجل حقوق المراه
الايرانيه من المنفى اثنتان منهن تقيمان
في امريكا الرئيس الفرنسي قال ان النساء
في ايران ياخذنا هذه المعركه بشجاعه
استثنائيه في ظل تهديد حياتهن وحياتي
احبائين واضاف انها احتجاجهن على حكم
النظام قد فجر الفقاعه الايدولوجيه التي
كانت طهران ترسلها الى العالم بان
الايرانيين لا يريدون القيم الغربيه لكن
اللافت كان اللهجه الحاده وصف الاحتجاجات
الايرانيه بالثوره ليست المره الاولى
بالمناسبه اضافه الى اسراره على ضروره
تجديد العقوبات الاوروبيه التي تستهدف
الحرس الثوري معبرا عن تايذه لوجود رد فعل
ديبلوماسيا قويا وفرض عقوبات على شخصيات
النظام المسؤوله عن قمع هذه الثوره اضف
الى ذلك حزمه العقوبات الاوروبيه الجديده
التي قالت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه انا
لينا بيربك ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يهدف من
وراءها لارسال اشاره واضحه الى المسؤولين
الذين يعتقدون انهم يستطيعون قمعه وترويع
وقتل شعبهم دون عوض مشيره الى ان العقوبات
الجديده ستهدف الدائره الداخليه للسلطه في
الحرس الثوري الايراني وهياكل تمويلهم على
وجه الخصوص
نموذج
من اجل فرد عقوبه تستهدف خاصه الحرس
الثوريه وافراد النظام في كل مره حول هذا
الموضوع نحاول ان ننظر الى الحقائق
المفيده واعتقد انه ما دامت الامور تمضي
قدما فسيتم طرح هذا السؤال اكثر فاكثر نعم
انا اؤيد ذلك لان لدينا رد فعل دبلوماسي
قوي وعقوبات على اشخاص في النظام مسؤولين
عما يحدث في قمع هذه الثوره
وكانت الجوله الاولى من العقوبات التي
اقرت في اكتوبر الماضي شملت حضر سفر
وتجميد اصول لخمسه عشر شخصا ومؤسسه لهم
صله بوفاه الشابه امين وحمله القمع على
الاحتجاجات بينما شملت الحزم الجديده 31
اسما بينهم وزير الداخليه الايراني بسبب
انتهاكاته حقوق الانسان مشكلات او ازمات
ايران لا تاتي فورادا او ربما اراد
الطهران ذلك ازمه برنامجها النوويه عالقه
ولا اتفاق نووي حتى يلوح في الافق حتى
ايضا الرئيس الفرنسي كان له راي في قصه
نووي الايراني الطويله فمكروه لا يرى
مجالا لاحراز تقدم في اتفاق ايران النووي
في الوقت الراهن وفي وقت توجه فيه طهران
غضبا داخليا همم تواجه غضبا شعبيه وخارجيا
دوليا تستدعي حلولا من خزائنها تضرب مقارا
لاحزاب كرديه في كردستان العراق قصف ادى
الى شخصين واصابه ثمانيه على الاقل بجروح
في سلسله ضربات بالطائرات المسيره
والصواريخ وهو الخبر الذي ورد منذ قليل
باذنه المملكه العربيه السعوديه لهذه
الطلبات
[موسيقى]
هذا الهروب الى الخارج لم يدخل على
احتجاجات الشارع التي تستمر بالاتساع رغم
القمعي والعنف المتوسط وكاله انباء نشطاء
حقوق الانسان الايرانيه هرانه افادت بان
336 متظاهرا لقوا حتفهم حتى الان في
الاحتجاجات كما تم اعتقال ما يقرب من
15,000 شخص في عمومي البلاد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]